the killing of Jamaal hisagi sparked a
media firestorm televised crusade by
journalists pundits columnist week after
month journalist Jamaal khashoggi Jamal
khashoggi smoke machine Jamal has shows
you tomorrow the disappearance of
Washington Post contributor he walked
into a building and never came out of
the building
the murder happened khashoggi had died
media anger is building any US response
should hand John what if murder at the
Saudi consulate and is almost overnight
the Saudi government was made a pariah
an outcast directly accused of killing
have cruelly one man Saudi government
denies its complicit saying it was done
by rogue elements and suddenly suddenly
everyone remembers the war in Yemen
Congress are beginning to catch on to
the nature of this regime likely they
are not telling us the truth about what
happened to Jamal khashoggi why would we
believe them that they are not
intentionally hitting civilians inside
Yemen this really needs to alter our
relationship we need to bring an end to
the conflict in Yemen
make no mistake what's happening in
Yemen is awful
one of the worst humanitarian crises
currently happening in the world
[Music]
it could be that the media the bulk of
it now realizes how awful things are in
Yemen or it could be that they're using
it for different ends President Trump
taking a stunningly dismissive tone
about any possible Saudi leadership role
why he's going so far out of his way to
cover for the country and specifically
the ruler that carried out this killing
for president Trump it doesn't seem to
matter whether the fact support what the
Saudis say the thing is of course Yemen
has been a growing graveyard for over
three years three long blood-stained
years and the pundits the politicians by
and large have ignored it case in point
according to a media watchdog America's
MSNBC news channel did one single
segment on the war in Yemen in the
course of a year by comparison
MSNBC add four hundred and fifty five
segments that stormy Daniels a porn
actress who claims to have slept with
Donald Trump before he became president
four hundred and fifty five and one on
Yemen but now things have changed George
it changed everything
Saudi Arabia's former supporters a
jumping ship
I changed my mind because I'm pissed the
way the administration's handled the
Saudi Arabia then is just not acceptable
interesting isn't it have a death of one
man sparked immediate global outrage and
indignation with the deaths of thousands
and thousands in Yemen and Saudi
Arabia's hand drew only murmured concern
you